let's talk about the fashion first I
mean by the way Jamie Lee Curtis I just
keep crashing like I just happen to be
like right behind wherever she's being
happier to be the SAG Ambassador yeah
it's really cool and you're nominated
Ambassador is just if that entails just
crashing her interviews then that's a
great job sign me up but you're also a
nominee tonight how does it feel has it
sunk in
oh
cause no
but it's cool yeah it's so amazing to
see the cast back together because I
think it's been like a year since you
guys were insisted I just saw Adam
he's one of my best friends he's so
handsome I know you look beautiful tell
me a secret about this look tonight a
secret about it
I don't know was it first pick were you
it was the first pick let me think if
there's anything interesting yeah is it
comfortable do you have shoes under
there not comfortable I am wearing shoes
the shoes aren't that interesting but
they're just like this tall give you
some Heights giving me some hype because
I'm I'm very small natural inspired by
anything in particular or you just saw
it knew you had to wear it when I tried
this on I've like I've never felt like a
movie star in my entire life but I I
tried this on and I was like wow I look
like a movie star you are a star baby
okay you are my manifesting I'm
manifesting being this girl
um okay so what do we got to do to get
you in the next season of White Lotus
um I guess Mike's not gonna be here
tonight
I know you do it if he asked you to come
back I mean I don't know anyone that
wouldn't right but yeah no there's a lot
of cool things that could happen with
Porsha yeah also did you see this
campaign for Pam Anderson to play
Tanya's sister in the next I heard about
that yeah amazing you'd rehearsal I'm
trying to get Jamie Lee in it though
yeah yeah real quick there's so much
attention on your cast and like who's
dating who do you pay attention to any
of that do you know it's something we
don't no I don't know anything I know
nothing you know I'd rather ask you
about Jonas Brothers real quick what was
it like to have that full circle moment
and be in the Big Brothers I know
everything about the Jonas Brothers
you're a long time long time yeah now
your buddies with them like what well
I don't know if they would consider me
their buddy but I would consider us very
close friends yeah very very close is
that a cool experience it was beyond
cool it was actually the coolest thing
I've ever done I literally moved to LA
when I was 16 to be an actor and one of
my dreams was like I remember telling my
mom one night when we were like living
in this old woman's house and we were
like sharing a bed together and I was
like mom do you think I'll ever be
famous enough to meet the Jonas Brothers
and now you're in their music video stop
it yes
yeah it's it's genuinely a dream come
true I'm happy for you and enjoy tonight
you look like a movie star
[Music]